[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour couvée
[Musique]
les baleines sont
des êtres sensibles très sociables, très intelligents, très
conscients d'eux-mêmes et ils
sont traqués à l'aide de sonar et de toutes
sortes d'appareils de très haute technologie afin
de  trouvez-les et ils sont tués avec les
harpons explosifs c'est une mort très douloureuse
cela peut prendre partout où nous
avons enregistré à 25 minutes pour qu'une
baleine meure après avoir été harponnée
et tirée à plusieurs reprises avec des
tirs de fusil aucune baleine ne meurt instantanément c'est un
mythe que les Japonais aimeraient
montrer et bien sûr les images du
navire du gouvernement australien
illustrent très clairement que nous ne
savons même pas quel est le statut des
populations de baleines là-bas, mais nous
savons qu'elles sont en difficulté  tous les
cétacés sont en difficulté dans le monde et le
Japon ne tue pas ces baleines pour se
nourrir, ils ne les mangent pas, il y a des
milliers de tonnes de viande de baleine là-dedans
dans leurs entrepôts congelés en ce moment,
ils le font parce qu'un  ils ne veulent pas que
quelqu'un leur dise quoi faire et
aux personnes qui siègent au conseil d'
administration par intérim pour les
sociétés baleinières, c'est en fait une
société appartenant au gouvernement, ce sont en fait d'
anciens politiciens et des amis du
gouvernement si vous mettez fin à la chasse à la baleine  vous mettez fin à
leurs emplois à six chiffres et aussi l'équipage
qui travaille sur ces navires est membre d'
un syndicat contrôlé par les
Yakuza et les Yakuza ont beaucoup d'
influence politique au Japon,
le fait est qu'il ne gagne pas d'
argent c'est  subventionné à hauteur d'
environ 50 millions u.s.  dollars chaque année,
ils ont même pris 30 millions de dollars du
fonds de secours du salami et l'ont donné
aux baleiniers afin que les gens du
monde entier qui essaient d'aider
les Japonais à se remettre du
tsunami voient leur argent utilisé et donné
au  entreprises baleinières pour subventionner leurs
opérations Le Japon prétend qu'ils
tuent des baleines pour la recherche et c'est un
très très faux mensonge flagrant qui a
été réprimé par la
Cour internationale de justice qui a statué en 2014
que ce n'est pas scientifique et c'est en
fait  illégal la Commission baleinière internationale
dit que ce n'est pas scientifique
il n'y a pas un seul
article scientifique international évalué par des pairs qui a été publié depuis que cela a
commencé en 1987
que peut faire un président macron il peut
faire beaucoup chaque branche est signataire de l'
International  La Commission baleinière et les
signataires ont le pouvoir d'exercer
une pression économique sur des pays comme le
Japon, la Norvège ou l'Islande qui
continuent à  baleine sauver le monde
de nous-mêmes va être une
chose en cours L'humanité est déterminée à
détruire l'environnement naturel
qui nous soutient si nous éliminons les baleines,
ce qui aura de graves
conséquences graves pour la diversité de nos océans
et bien sûr des conséquences très graves
pour  Humanité